you know obviously we can bury our head
in the sand and say it's never aliens
like many of my colleagues say and it's
a self-fulfilling
prophecy if you if you never look you
will never find if you are not ready to
find
wonderful things you will never discover
them
and the other thing i would like to say
is reality
doesn't care whether you ignore it or
not you can ignore reality but it's
still there
yes so we can all agree based on twitter
that aliens don't exist that um
was a rock we can all agree and you will
get a lot of likes
they will have a big crowd of supporters
and everyone we
will be happy and give each other awards
and honors and so forth
but um might still be an alien artifact
who cares what humans agree on yeah
there is a reality out there
and we have to be modest enough to
recognize
that we should make our statements based
on evidence
science is not about ourself it's not
about
glorifying our image it's not about
getting honors
prizes you know a lot of the scientific
a lot of the academic activity is geared
towards
creating your echo chamber where you
have students postdocs repeating your
mantras
so that your voice is heard loudly so
that you can get more honors prizes
recognition
that's not the purpose of science the
purpose is to figure out what nature is
right and in the process of doing that
it's a learning experience
you make mistakes you know einstein made
three mistakes at the end of his career
he argued that in the 1930s he argued
that black holes don't exist
gravitational waves don't exist and
quantum mechanics doesn't have spooky
action at a distance yes
and all three turned out to be wrong
okay so
the point is that if you work at the
frontier of then you make mistakes it's
inevitable because you can't tell what
is
true or not and avoiding making mistakes
in order to preserve your image
makes you extremely boring okay you will
get a prize but you will be a
boring scientist because you will keep
repeating things we already know
if you want to make progress if you want
to innovate you have to take risks and
you have to look at the evidence
it's a dialogue with nature you don't
know the
the truth in advance you let nature tell
you educate you
and then you you realize that what you
thought before
is incorrect and a lot of my colleagues
prefer to be in a state where they have
a monologue you know if you look at
these people that work on string theory
yes
uh they have a monologue they know what
and in fact
their monologue is centered on
anti-deceiter space which we don't live
in now you know it's to me it's just
like the olympics you know you
you define a hundred meters and you say
whoever runs this hundred meters
is the best athlete the fastest you know
and
it's completely arbitrary you could have
decided it would be 50 meters or 20
meters
who cares you just measure the ability
of people this way
so you define antidecital space as a
space where you do your mathematical
gymnastics
and then you find who can do it the best
and you give jobs based on that you give
prizes best
but as we said before you know nature
doesn't care about
you know the prizes that you give to
each other
it cares you know it has its own reality
and
we should figure it out and it's not
about us the scientific activity is
about
figuring out nature and sometimes we may
be wrong our image will not
be preserved but it's that's the fun you
know
i um kids explore the world out of
curiosity and
i always want to maintain my childhood
curiosity and
i don't care about the labels that i
have in fact
having tenure is is exactly the
opportunity to
behave like a child because you can make
mistakes yeah and
i was asked by the harvard gazette you
know the the new
the pravda of harvard uh
what what is the one thing that you
would like
to change about the world yes and i said
i would like my colleagues to behave
more like kids
yeah that's the one thing i would like
them to do because
something bad happens to these kids when
they become tenured professors they
start to worry about their ego
yeah and about themselves more than
about the purpose of science which is
you know curiosity driven figuring out
from evidence evidence is the key
so when an object shows anomalies like
what's the problem discussing you know
whether it's artificial or not
you know so there was i should tell you
there was a mainstream
paper in nature published saying it must
be natural
that's it it's unusual but it must be
natural
period and then at the same time that
those main some other mainstream
scientists
tried to explain the properties yes and
they came up with interpretations like
it's a dust bunny you know the kind that
you find in a household a collection of
dust particles
pushed by sunlight something we have
never seen before
or it's a hydrogen iceberg it actually
evaporates like a comet
but hydrogen is transparent you don't
see it and that's why we don't see the
commentary
again we have never seen something like
that in both cases the objects would not
survive the long journey we discussed it
in a paper that i wrote afterwards
but my point is those that try to
explain the unusual properties
went into great length at discussing
things that we have never seen before
okay so even when you think about the
natural origin
you have to come up with scenarios that
of things that were never seen before
uh and by the way they look less
plausible to me personally
but my point is if we discuss things
that were never seen before
right why not discuss why not
contemplate
an artificial origin what's the problem
why do people have
this pushback you know i worked on on
dark matter
and we don't know what most of the
matter in the universe is
it's called dark metal it's just an
acronym because
we have no clue we simply don't know so
it could be all kinds of particles
and over the years people suggested
weakly interacting massive particles
axions all kinds of particles
and experiments were made they cost
hundreds of millions of dollars
they put upper limits constraints that
ruled out
many of the possibilities that were
proposed as natural initially
the mainstream community regarded it as
a mainstream activity to search
the nature of the dark matter and they
nobody complained that it's speculative
to consider weakly interacting massive
particles
now i ask you why is it speculative to
consider
extraterrestrial technologies we have
a proof that it exists here on earth yes
we also know
that the conditions of of of earth are
reproduced
in billions of systems throughout the
milky way galaxy
so what's more conservative than to say
if you arrange for similar
conditions you get the same outcome how
can you imagine this to be specula it's
not speculative at all
and nevertheless it's regarded the
periphery and at the same time you have
physicists theoretical physics
working on extra dimensions super
symmetry
uh super string theory the multiverse
maybe we live in a simulation all of
these ideas that have no
grounding in reality some of which
sound to me like you know just like what
someone would say
uh science fiction basically because you
have no way to test it
uh you know through experiments and
experiments really are key it's not just
the nuance
you say okay forget about experiment and
some philosophers try to say
you know if there is a consensus what's
the problem the point is
it's key then that's what galileo it's
key to have feedback from reality
you know you can think that you have a
billion dollar or that you are more
rich than you know uh elon musk
that's fine you can feel very happy
about it
you can talk about it with your friends
and all of you will be happy and
think about what you can do with the
money then you go to an atm machine and
you make an experiment
you check how much money you have in in
your checking account
and if it turns out that you know you
you don't have much you can't
you can't materialize your dreams
okay so you realize you have a reality
check yes and my point is
without experiments giving you a reality
check without the atm machine showing
you whether your ideas are bankrupt or
not
without putting skin in the game and by
skinning the game i mean
don't just talk about theoretical ideas
make them testable
if you don't make them testable they're
worthless
they're just like theology that is not
testable
by the way theology has some tests let
me give you
that's interesting three examples yes um
it turns out that my book already
inspired a phd student at harvard in the
english department
to pursue a phd in that direction and
she invited me to the phd exam a couple
of months ago
and in the exam one of the examiners a
professor
asked her do you know why jordano bruno
was burnt at the stake and she said
no i think it's because he was an
obnoxious guy and
irritated a lot of people yes which is
true
but the professor said no it's because
giordano bruno said
that other stars are just like the sun
and they could have a planet like the
earth around them
that could host life and that was
offensive to the church
why was it offensive because there is
the possibility that this life
sinned okay and if that life
sinned on planets around other stars it
should have been
saved by christ and then you need
multiple copies of
christ and that's unacceptable how can
you have
duplicates of christ and so they burned
the guy
it was about that's okay i'm just like
loading this all in because that's kind
of brilliant
so he he was actually already it's not
just about the stars it's anticipating
that there could be other life forms
yeah
like why if this star if there's other
stars
why would it be special why would our
star be special
he was making the right argument and he
would just follow that
all along to say like there should be
other earth like
places there should be other life and
then that copies of christ
yes so that was offensive so i said i
said to that
i said to that professor i said great
you know i wanted to introduce some
scientific tone to the discussion
and i said this is great because now you
basically laid the foundation for an
experimental test of this theology
what is the test we now know that other
stars are like the sun
and we know they have planets like the
earth around them so suppose we find
life there
and we figure out that they sinned
then we asked them did you witness
christ
and if they say no it means that this
this theology
is ruled out so there is an experimental
test so this is experimental test number
one
another experimental test you know uh
in the bible you know in the old
testament abraham
uh was heard the voice
the voice of god to sacrifice
his son right only son and
that's what the story says now suppose
abraham
my name by the way had a voice memo
up on his cell phone yes he could have
pressed this up
and recorded the voice of god and that
would have been experimental evidence
that god exists
right fortunately he didn't but
it's an experimental test right there is
a third example i should tell
and that is elie wiesel attributed this
story to martin buber
but it's not clear whether it's true or
not at any event the story goes that
martin buber you know he was a
philosopher and he said
you know the christians argue that jesus
you know
the messiah arrived already
and will come back again in the future
the jews
argue the messiah never came
and will arrive in the future so he said
why argue both sides agree
that the messiah will arrive in the
future
when the messiah arrives we can ask
whether he or she
came before you know like visited us and
then figure it out and
one side so again experimental test of a
theology
so even theology if it puts
a skin in the game you know if it makes
a prediction could be tested right
uh so why can't string theories test
themselves
or why can't you know even cosmic
inflation that's another model that
you know one of the inventors from mit
alan guth argues that it's not
falsifiable
uh i are my point is a theory that
cannot be falsified is not helpful
because it means that you can't make
progress you cannot improve your
understanding
of nature the only way for us to learn
about nature is by
making hypotheses that are testable
doing the experiments and learning
whether we are correct or not
so be and couple that with a curiosity
and open mindedness that allows us to
explore
all kinds of possible hypotheses but
always
the pursuit of those the the scientific
rigor around those hypotheses is
ultimately get evidence knowledge is
of of what nature is should be a
dialogue with nature
yes rather than a monologue beautifully
put
you